Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez are
planning the holidays together and with
their exes yeah X's it's about family
and it's about love a source tells E.T
that the newlyweds are busy figuring out
the most festive time of year and their
schedules are hectic but they're looking
forward to a huge holiday celebration
for both Thanksgiving and Christmas I
think that's a big part of what makes
life satisfying and interesting and
according to ET Source a big part of
that planning revolves around their
kiddos and their exes Jen shares 14 year
old twins Max and Emmy with her
ex-husband Marc Anthony you have your
priorities my babies and their happiness
and their health comes first while Ben
and his ex Jennifer Garner have three
kids together sixteen-year-old Violet 13
year old Seraphina and 10 year old
Samuel quote they have to sort things
out with both sets of kids and their
exes but they would love to have have
all the kids together with them as one
big family and are working on that now
the kids come first and then everything
else kind of Falls in line after that
the source notes that Jennifer Garner is
happy for Ben and likes that he is so
happy and adds that she wishes him
nothing but the best while she's happy
in her own relationship with businessman
John Miller and when it comes to
co-parenting ET Source says there's no
bad blood let me do our best as for
JLo's other ex Alex Rodriguez whom she
split with last year
ET Source says that he told the triple
threat that he will always be there for
her and added that he's cool with
everything and doing his own thing I had
five years of of an incredible life and
and partnership and also with my
daughters we learned so much and now we
have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years how
do we make the next five years better
because of Lessons Learned as for
a-rod's kids seventeen-year-old Natasha
and 14 year old Ella our source says
they're not really in touch with JLo
anymore quote they talk here and there
via social media and a birthday wish
email but there's nothing else really
beyond that you know I'm so grateful for
our life and our kids and this time
still our source ads they know she would
help them out in any way she could and
that she has a huge heart
[Music]
foreign
foreign